hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion
since its invention in 1989 by Tim
Bernice Lee the web has been a place for
people to share thoughts ideas and
generally communicate
but today something is changing what if
some of the users that you interact with
in comment sections or social media
sites are not human
there's a theory dubbed the dead
internet theory that takes things
further broadly it states that most of
the activity on the Internet is in fact
the work of bots
have we witnessed the death of the
internet and not even noticed
since the fledgling start of language AI
systems most people boast that they can
tell apart a human conversation versus
one with an AI system but what happens
if this isn't the case or see an
interesting example of this later in the
episode but for now let's Dive Into the
Dead internet Theory
[Music]
in 2021 a user by the name of Illuminati
pirate posted a long ranting document
called the dead internet theory on the
Agora Road forum
the original post contained some
questionable language but there are some
interesting ideas contained within it
the general thesis is this every day
content is created accessed and shared
by what we think are people but
increasingly this content is being
generated by Bots Bots without a
heartbeat Bots without thoughts or
feelings the internet has basically
become a sea of bots with some islands
of human activity and it's quote sterile
and devoid of people for all intents and
purposes the internet is dead
the dead internet Theory claims that AI
content is mass produced to manipulate
users thoughts and feelings control
populations and manufacture fake
consumers for products that all does
sound plausible but where the theory
goes off the rails is by claiming that
the internet is controlled by a small
group of people these internet overlords
use these spots to spy on us and control
Humanity I think the rise of AI Bots is
more to do with profit and occasionally
geopolitical foreign interference it's
not some evil group of mustache twirlers
and besides back in 2021 when the theory
was first proposed there was no
widespread generative AI flooding the
entire internet with Bots would have
taken too many resources and too much
coordination to be feasible for only
such a small group of people
excluding the nefarious plot part of the
theory how realistic is the rest of it
the dead internet Theory can only be one
of three things absurd a reality or a
prophecy of what's to come
which is it the craziest thing is that
the ideas expressed are only becoming
more true as time progresses
there's no getting away from the fact
that humans proportional relationship to
bots is changing in 2021 a study showed
that only 57.7 percent of users on the
internet were human harmful bots made up
27.7 an increase of 2.1 percent from the
previous year
good Bots can be things like search
engine crawlers whereas bad Bots can
carry out malicious attacks the overall
rate of Bot growth was negative but
recently this is reversed and the
proportion of humans is the lowest in
eight years
and most concerningly bad Bots are
increasing at a rate of 5 per year
another estimate says that Bots can be
up to 64 of the internet
whilst data isn't available just yet the
burgeoning abilities of generative AI
will undoubtedly impact these numbers in
the future
the theory also talks about AI
influences although not so easy in 2021
today it wouldn't be hard to set up an
Instagram profile of someone generated
entirely in mid-journey
[Music]
day one so the first step in creating
the next viral influencer the next
Charlie demilio the next Addison Ray is
well creating that paid ten dollars for
Mid Journey V5 to get a slightly less
horrifying influencer to make famous
introducing
April Isabella where I cannot believe
this is not a real person what the
actual
hi now of course the first thing that
every famous influencer needs is an
Instagram so I started April's profile
and used chat gbt to write her a buyer
making soap and candles learning
languages and stargazing collecting
vinyl and playing games plant mom quirky
girl okay then I use mid-journey again
to generate some photos that would match
the quirky white girl aesthetic that we
all know in picture of a Plus Gym one of
her hanging out with friends and of
course one of her at Starbucks
surprisingly April's posts were actually
getting liked somehow now to be fair
they were definitely all bonds but
that's not important
[Music]
in May of 2023 influencer Karen metri
made an AI version of herself to sell to
fans Die Hard followers could pay one
dollar a minute to talk to her well the
chat gpt4 version of her anyway it's the
AI version of the influencer that could
be their personal girlfriend
it's straight out of Black Mirror but it
is the kind of thing we'll see more of
in the future
the theory goes on to state that social
media may be mostly Bots too an article
by the publication the Atlantic looked
at examples of tweets with the exact
same text repeated by countless accounts
with eerily similar profile pictures and
most weirdly of all these accounts had
huge engagement levels far more than
would be expected of an account of this
nature
in 2018 data scientist Tom Leung warned
of an inversion point where YouTube Bots
would make up a larger percentage of
viewership than real people this was
distort analytics and make it harder to
identify real traffic from fake traffic
basically it would destroy YouTube
there's no evidence that this has
happened on YouTube just yet but on
Facebook it's already happened
in 2019 Facebook shut down a staggering
5.4 billion fake accounts more than
twice the number of real accounts on the
site
it's a trend that's set to continue with
experts from the Copenhagen Institute
for future studies predicting that buyer
2025-2026 nearly 99 of the internet will
be generated by artificial intelligence
the Bots will win they will outweigh
humans and in this scenario the internet
may be very well dead after all
not all of this internet traffic will be
bad though a lot of these Bots will
perform helpful tasks for people like
customer service Assistance or even Auto
GPT style stuff where you can ask it to
go out to the internet and do anything
for you but regardless computer
scientists will have to come up with
novel ways to mitigate the damage
the past it was easy to spot a bot they
were clunky unhuman in their appearance
and communication style so we could just
ignore those Instagram DMS saying that
we'd want a gift card or an email that
claims that we're due a huge tax refund
and we could just get on with our day
but as AI evolves the line will blur
between human produced content and AI
generated content I encourage you to
watch a video by the YouTube channel
Jubilee in it they ran an interesting
experiment by only using questions and
answers in text format six humans had
the task of guessing who among them was
a secret AI imposter my goal would be to
blend in with the human competitors as
much as possible without giving any
clues that I am an AI
when people are constantly on their
phones and not present in the moment lol
noises because just like stop
foreign
[Music]
is going to crash into my living room
every time a loud one flies over
[Music]
I don't know I was just being extra I
guess I was just numbering like one two
three trying to be organized maybe I was
thinking too much like an AI but I
wouldn't have did that I think I would
have won I'm sure that I answered the
questions pretty quickly which is
probably why I also got voted out
because they were kind of short and
sweet what's the craziest dream you've
had
the night I got my wisdom teeth removed
I had a dream that glass was coming out
of my gums where my teeth had been
a robot
no LOL if the lights turn green that you
have successfully voted out the AI and
you win the lights turn red that means
the AI still in the box and you all lose
three
two one
yes money
it was extremely hard for them to tell
and multiple humans were voted out for
being AI it just goes to show you how
far we've come
in the 1950s British computer scientist
Alan Turing developed a test to measure
a machine's ability to exhibit
intelligent Behavior indistinguishable
from that of a human
it's called the touring test and it's
become The Benchmark for realistic
language AI
if you want to have a go at it yourself
AI 21 Labs has released a gamified
social version of the Turing test called
human or not
in the game users are invited to have a
conversation and decide whether they're
speaking to a human or a robot
as we all know developments are moving
at lightning speed
as of today though only two AI systems
are capable of passing the touring test
albeit in narrow settings Google's
Lambda was the first chat bot to pass
the touring test in July of 2022 and of
course open ai's chat GPT became the
second one to pass the test
we're also starting to see studies that
suggest humans are beginning to trust AI
to validate facts and make decisions
over other humans
a 2020 study by researchers at the
University of Georgia found that given a
choice of trusting medical information
provided by humans or generated by AI
people were more likely to trust the
information provided by the AI
you hypnotized
at a time when information online should
be endless browsing the web can feel
repetitive like there's nothing new to
see but soon there may be swaths of text
conversations images and even whole
websites and videos generated by AI
from scammers to fake reviews to online
generated information being filled with
lies and half truths if we're not
careful we could be entering a
post-truth world
there's a lot of issues coming our way
but there is a ray of Hope many
companies are starting to fight AI with
AI there's a growing trend of creating
AI detection tools a prototype also
exists that takes a paragraph of text
and ascertains whether or not it was
generated by AI this can be achieved by
tweaking the choice of words selected by
chat GPT that can be picked up by a tool
looking for AI generated text but all of
this would be unnoticeable to the user
such technology could be adapted for
other forms of generative AI Google and
Microsoft are working on their own
version for images
these are all great steps and if more
companies follow suit we may at least
stand a chance of combating the wave of
low quality AI stuff coming critical
thinking seeking further context and
technological literacy will be
increasingly important the bottom line
is we all have to be more discerning
foreign
[Music]
conclusion while the original dead
internet Theory may be a bit crackpot it
ended up being a prediction of a likely
future if nothing changes generic AI
generated comments and posts will take
up more of our online spaces but ending
on a positive note there is something
that can be and is being done about it
from Google's digital markets to
Microsoft's content credentials further
developing these safeguards are arguably
as important as the development of the
technology itself education on media
literacy and critical thinking skills
may go a long way too although once we
do have a framework in place we can
enjoy the productivity and creativity
gains brought about by using AI as a
tool and as an aid
alright so that is the dead internet
Theory and how AI is playing into that
hope you learned something if you did
feel free to have a look around on the
channel there's plenty of interesting
stuff on here on science technology
business and history anyway my name is
and you've been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next episode cheers guys
have a good one
foreign
[Music]